Speaker 1: Let's start today with a sort of
thick and meaty policy segment.
And let's talk about Social Security in the
context of this.
And it's been much requested by many of you
is the absolute apoplexy from Republicans
at the mere suggestion that over the last
few years they've hinted at and even sometimes
overtly said maybe we should cut Social Security,
maybe the cuts would be lower benefits, maybe
the cuts would be you have to work longer,
meaning raise the retirement age or whatever
the case may be.
But when Joe Biden said at his State of the
Union address a couple of weeks ago, some
of these Republicans want to cut Social Security.
They went crazy and started saying Joe Biden
is a liar and we would never do that.
And on and on and on.
And then yesterday on CNBC incomes former
Vice President Mike Pence, and he says, oh,
we should definitely put on the table that
we might cut Social Security and Medicare.
They've spent weeks saying we would never
do that.
Stop accusing us of maybe wanting to be open
to considering the possibility of ever cutting
Social Security and Medicare.
And then here's Mike Pence saying, oh, yeah,
no, like we should definitely think of that
because of the debt, is.
Speaker 2: That while I respect the speaker's
commitment to take Social Security and Medicare
off the table for the debt ceiling negotiations,
we've got to put them on the table in the
long term.
And right now, President Biden's policy is
insolvency.
I mean, we're looking at a debt crisis in
this country over the next 25 years that is
driven by entitlements.
And nobody in Washington, D.C., wants to talk
about it.
I've been going around the country.
I'm going to continue to try and do my part.
Yeah, people, what.
Speaker 1: A heroic thing he's doing.
What would you do about entitlements?
Speaker 2: Well, I think first and foremost,
you have to explain to people what's going
on.
We've got a $32 trillion national debt right
now, Andrew.
Having a national debt the same size as our
nation's economy is unsustainable.
Last time that happened was right after.
Oh, I don't disagree with you.
I'm just curious what's on the for you on
entitlements?
What's on the table?
Well, I think it begins with education.
It begins with having the American people
understand.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So twice, like what exactly would
you do?
Well, we got to tell people all about it.
Remember what happened at the State of the
Union when Joe Biden merely suggested some
Republicans are open to cutting.
Speaker 3: Take the economy hostage?
I get it.
Unless I agree to the record, I can't.
All of you at home should know what those
plans are now.
Instead of making the wealthy pay their fair
share.
Some Republicans, some Republicans want Medicare
and Social Security sunset.
I'm not saying that a majority.
Unidentified: No.
Let me give you anybody who doesn't contact
my office.
I'll give you a copy.
Speaker 3: I'll give you a copy of the proposal.
Speaker 1: And there was you some Marjorie
Trader GREENE standing and screaming.
So they say for weeks and weeks.
No, we would never, ever, ever, ever, ever
do that.
And then here goes Mike Pence.
And he's like, Oh, yeah, it should absolutely
be on the table.
We have way too much debt.
So let's talk about the truth on this talking
point so that we can all understand what is
going on, because the right says Social Security
is insolvent.
It just doesn't work financially.
It doesn't work.
Here's the truth.
And the truth is it's it's a good thing and
a bad thing that it's really clear what's
going on.
Because sometimes when things are so clear
and simple, the right loves to pretend like
they're really complicated.
Despite Republicans claiming Social Security
is insolvent, meaning unable to pay the benefits
that it owes or will owe people.
If we do nothing, we change nothing at all
about Social Security.
There is enough money to pay full benefits
until 2035.
That means, like if you keep doing just the
inflation adjustments for cost of living to
what people get, you change nothing about
what people in other than continuing to do
the inflation adjustment to the Social Security
cap like literally nothing changes until 2048,
2035.
There is no problem.
And if we continue with the do nothing scenario
starting in 2035, you can reduce benefits
to 80% of what they would be inflation adjusted
and then it still continues to be fine, making
no changes whatsoever other than moving benefits
from 180%.
Now, what is the reason that this is going
on?
Why is this even a conversation changing demographics.
More and more people are retiring relative
to the number of workers.
So as baby boomers continue to retire, the
number of people receiving benefits relative
to the number of people paying in is going
to fall out of balance towards the retirees.
And then secondly, people on average are living
longer, meaning that the estimates for how
long people are going to be receiving benefits,
it's more years because people are living
longer.
Okay.
Now, I think it's unacceptable to go down
to 80% of benefits.
But again.
With doing nothing.
Fine until 2035 and then fine for a very long
time on 80% of benefits.
I believe if you've paid in based on getting
100% of benefits, you should get them.
Okay.
But I've laid out the do nothing scenario.
It's not exactly insolvent, is it?
It's everything's fine for 11, 12 years, and
then we do a 20% reduction.
But let's fix it.
Okay.
How do we fix it?
There's quite a few ways.
They're relatively simple.
It's just a matter of finding the political
will to do it.
As a reminder, right now, in 2023, Social
Security contributions are made on your first
$160,000 that you earn per year.
Once you get beyond 160, you stop paying into
Social Security.
The amount that is paid in is 12.4%.
Now, many of you might say, David, I'm only
paying 6.2%.
The reason is that in a normal job, if you're
a W-2 employee, that 12.4% is divided between
you and your employer.
So instead of you paying 12.4%, you pay 6.2.
Your employer pays 6.2.
If you're self-employed like me, you pay the
full 12.4%.
Okay, so what can you do?
One thing you can do is you can increase that
rate.
You could say instead of 12.4%, it's going
to be something higher on that first hundred
and $60,000.
I don't like that idea because it disproportionately
hits those earning under 160,000.
But you could do that.
You could sense that a 12.4% were going to
pay 15%, and that's going to stretch out how
long we can pay 100% of benefits.
Second option, you can raise the cap so you
keep it at 12.4%.
But instead of paying that on your first hundred
and 60,000 that you make, maybe you paid on
your first 180 or maybe on your first 200.
That seems like a better option to me.
Number three, you could raise the retirement
age.
It's very controversial.
I don't like it, but you could say, well,
you've got to wait longer before you can get
benefits.
What I do like is giving a bonus if you delay
retirement by choice.
This is already part of the way it works.
And for people for whom this is new, I think
it's useful to know this stuff right now.
You can start receiving reduced benefits at
age 62.
The standard age to get benefits is 67.
So your 100% benefit would be if you say at
67 years of age.
I want to start getting the benefits from
62 to 67.
You get less.
And if you at age 67 say, I don't need the
money yet either because I have private retirement
or I'm going to continue working or whatever.
If you say I'm going to wait until I'm 68
or 69 or 70, you get even more benefits when
you do retire.
We could expand that and say, Hey, you know
what?
People are living longer and many people would
gladly delay getting their Social Security
benefits.
You could say if you choose to wait until
age 71 or 72 or 73, 74, you get more benefits,
which leaves money in the trust fund.
Then it can accrue earnings and gains.
You don't force anybody to do anything, but
you give an option.
That's interesting.
A fourth option is to move the money in the
Social Security trust fund to something with
potentially higher return, but with more risk.
Right now, Social Security invests in low
risk government bonds.
Very safe, very low return.
Without going into it, we're going to buy
Bitcoin.
You could slightly expand the list of investment
vehicles that Social Security trust fund can
be invested in with the idea that there will
be a little more volatility.
But over time you should get a higher return
and that could close that gap that will eventually
appear.
And then lastly, you could also increase immigration,
bring in people to work to pay into the system
in order to even out that ratio.
So we can fix this with some tweaks.
You could raise the cap a little bit and then
you could offer greater benefits to people
who choose to delay retirement a little more.
Increase immigration a little bit, to increase
the number of people paying in and consider
slightly higher yield but slightly higher
risk investments with some of the money.
It's not brain surgery, but it's a political
gridlock and we have the solutions.
If only we could get our elected officials
to put them in place.
Lastly, mixing this specific issue of the
Social Security trust fund generally with
that of the national debt is also very dishonest
because the truth is Social Security is its
own trust fund and we can manage and make
tweaks to that individually.
The conversation about the debt is fine, but
it really is a separate conversation.
So after weeks of saying we would never do
that, Mike Pence shows up and says, Oh yeah,
we should definitely consider that.